I did have the story pulled out check
this out from the post-millennial body
cam footage shows Paul Pelosi opened the
door for cops contradicting Biden doj
quote two officers opened the door to
see the foyer of the Pelosi residents Mr
Pelosi wearing a long-sleeved shirt to
Pap in shorts running shoes and a
sweatshirt and a Pap and Mr Pelosi
jointly gripping a hammer okay wait what
Pelosi opens the door
and then walks over or something he
opened the door for the cops
so there you go reports emerge from the
body camera footage captured by police
that they went in and 42 year old depap
allegedly assaulted Paul blah blah blah
spoke with the source familiar with the
Pelosi investigation who personally
viewed body camera video recording of
officers and the body cam video shows
Paul Pelosi opened the door for police
despite the doj saying otherwise now why
would the doj lie about this now we did
cover this yesterday but the reason I
wanted to bring it back up is now we
have um
more people covering the story but we
also have this from The Daily Mail
suspended NBC News correspondent Miguel
alumaguer breaks cover from his five
million dollar La home and hops in
Porsche to pick up flowers as
controversy controversy grows over his
report on Paul Pelosi's Hammer attack
yo how does this guy have a five million
dollar house and a Porsche
whoa and anybody he looks uh we're in
the wrong business I think no we're in
the business what are you talking about
we're not chills though but but I mean
also it's important it's important to
note this guy hasn't tweeted since being
suspended so he hasn't publicly talked
about after he got in trouble for what
was clearly reporting on something that
actually did happen after of course
listening to police officers and
Reporting what police officers told to
him he was suspended it after reporting
on yeah he got suspended he got in
trouble for reporting on the initial
claim that now NBC is reporting and
other news organizations are reporting
and now that there's allegedly
um you know uh dash cam and police
footage of so so he told the truth and
then he got in trouble for doing so and
now he has to bring Paul Pelosi flowers
yes maybe that's what I'm thinking but
but here's my here's my point
how does this guy have enough money
for this like it's kind of crazy I'm
sorry I know I know the salaries of
journalists something here is weird
his family's I mean it is true that
journalists come from typically come
from wealthy families yeah could have
money
could also maybe he invested well yeah
sure he could have gotten you know two
dollars a word for an article once and
really put that into fxt
sold just in time a five million dollar
house that's that's what do you think is
going on what's your I have no idea I
just think it's kind of weird that's
garbage well I mean actually yeah for
real though depending on where you are
yeah but uh you know in Compton wow five
million maybe but probably not something
really big in the nicer areas two in the
Hills I think Hassan has a five million
house in in the LA area right what a
good one little socialist he is yeah
well he deserves it it's a nice area La
gorgeous here's a guy who now by all
accounts appears to have accurately
reported some weird goings-on with Paul
Pelosi he gets suspended
we don't know why they're not explaining
themselves the story is being
corroborated turns out it was likely
true the dude who reported it is
unnaturally wealthy
I mean look if you're a cop and you were
investigating something like this you'd
be like how does a guy who was like a
journalist afford all of these things
sure I mean maybe he comes from a rich
family or something like that I'm just I
just think it's kind of weird I was a
police investigate him for being wealthy
though I'm not I'm not saying him I'm
saying he likes to get improving system
if you're if you're if you're a doctor
and then and you and you're wearing gold
chains and living in a 10 million dollar
house what's wrong with that they're
going to be like them this guy doesn't
have that you know like something
doesn't add up here he's selling Oxys
for sure right no exactly they're going
to be like something's going on and so
I'm kind of like hey this is kind of
weird I don't trust these people
I think the big thing the whole thing's
a racket anyway you'd be surprised how
much money journalists do make to it you
know to a certain NBC too yeah but this
and who's his wife probably someone in
the White House oh there you go that
explains it I guess he drives a 134
000 car yeah has a five million dollar
gated a gated home in Studio City
California oh okay I don't know why
you'd want that I agree I was in that
area it just seems like a good way to
die hey that's literally having like a
really expensive housing yeah yeah no no
no I lived in L.A for a long time and
it's just like yeah yeah hey I mean I
used to love it yeah it was great 20
years ago yeah but not now no it's not a
tense yeah a lot of times it's really
sad really it's like there used to be
that little area that was skid row and
then it's just all the greater now
greater Skid Row yeah it's so sad like
it was that one block downtown and then
just now it's all of downtown I know
it's crazy did you guys see uh Nancy
Pelosi won her District it was like 81
to like 19 or something something like
really yeah and it's crazy to me because
I'm like you'd think the 12th time you
stepped in human feces you'd be like I'm
not voting for the president just in
your driveway right but but yeah there's
like a video of a woman taking a dump in
the middle like a middle like a
residential street yeah and people are
like well there you go I was in uh I was
in LA and some woman walked into the
middle of the street and this was not in
a bad area and she just pulls her pants
off takes them off squats in the middle
of the street and just lets it go and I
was like oh that's California for you
this was this was this is a while ago
this was like seven years ago where
people clapping and saying How brave she
was yeah no people were kind of running
oh really yeah they were like like not
running running like speed walking with
like a little hustle to get into the
store to like get away from it you know
is she wearing a mask no no this is way
way before the pandemic oh and there was
a and then like I'm walking and I was
like oh well you know there you go
that's that's Los Angeles and I look to
my right and there was just like maybe
like seven or eight morbidly obese
homeless people and I just thought to
myself like man we got fat homeless
people we have fat starving people in
America isn't that crazy are they really
starving though what do you mean by that
malnutrition yeah there's so much crap
in their bodies that they're actually
starving but they're morbidly obese at
the same time isn't that the majority of
Americans though yeah like every time I
look in the mirror friend 40 of
Americans I think are obese
I mean that's really got to be throttled
it's really bad yeah and it's only going
to get worse I'm looking at Miguel and
it looks like he he always was a career
journalist and it looks like he got the
money from NBC news from his career
there so they they probably have been
paying him a lot he's been working in
journalism since uh 2000 and I think the
main takeaway here is that he's been
very quiet he hasn't tweeted since being
suspended and the the fact that NBC News
retracted the official story here which
now is correct really is the big story
here really is very very telling here
because I think there's a reason
Miguel's not speaking out because he
could say hey I did my job I got the
story right I said it first and I think
it's it's maybe something similar to
what happened with ABC News and Amy uh
what's her name
robishosher back with project Veritas
that exposed her when she did a good
story on Jeffrey Epstein saying that she
had Bill Clinton she had all the
politicians and and they of course axed
and deleted that story and made sure
that it never saw the day of light
there's probably something else more
Sinister here because again rich people
the most powerful people in the world
one have a bunch of security around them
so this whole story doesn't make sense
just on that
just one aspect of it but again as I
mentioned yesterday I'm sick of
speculating what happened here I'm just
going to imagine the worst possible
thing and they were sacrificing babies
and doing horrible things to them well
prove me wrong show me evidence
otherwise they were sacrificing babies
let's let's try this one on this story
about this uh almager guy if we're gonna
if we're gonna assume the worst then
it's NBC News pays this man an
exorbitant amount of money so that he
lies on TV
and then he doesn't question it because
he doesn't want to lose the big cash
that's called the job of an anchor
that's what they all get paid to do and
the other thing is he's got a five
million dollar home he might be still
quiet because he
he's kind of Vindicated now they might
he might be able to sue them for
wrongful termination
he's suspended yeah but they're with pay
oh is he just suspended yeah look I'm
willing to bet they went to him and said
Hey look it's a bad time for the story
because the midterm's coming up so just
lie low for a bit and we'll give you a
bonus
yeah if you're making that kind of money
they're not just going to suspend you
and expect you not to say anything and
he's got to be getting money if he's not
tweeted I've told this story before how
I was like when I worked at fusion and I
said hey I don't want to be here anymore
and they were like well you're under
contract and I was like well this is
stupid and then a few months later they
gave me a call and they deposited tens
of thousands of dollars in my bank
account and then I was like yeah I still
don't want to be here and they're like
no and then a few months later like okay
contract yourself you can leave and I
was like bye I mean the majority of
journalists I mean a lot of them have
substance abuse problems a lot of them
that I've that I've personally met and
hung out with especially I I one year I
got really hammered with the White House
Press Corps all of them depressed as
hell all of them are like yeah I just I
just got a family I I got bills to pay I
want to make sure that my kids go to a
good school they give me a script I read
it that's it and I think it's it's more
clearer by the day that they're just
doing the bidding of the special
interest of the powerful people of the
Pelosi's that at the end of the day
dictate what the people get to know
about because this story clearly
highlights how they covered up key facts
and evidence of what actually happened
here just to make themselves look better
just to cover up the truth from the
general public and until I see videos
until I see actual evidence there's no
reason to give the government and these
people the benefit of the doubt always
think the worst I you know I was
thinking because someone super chatted
about ligma Johnson
and I'm just thinking if we if we
started a political party yeah
like if that was on the ballot a lot of
people would be like yup and they might
for sure just meme a ligma Johnson
candidate into like the Libertarians
have been trying so hard to get a
candidate in Congress but if you put
ligma Johnson a lot of people are
probably going to be like it's it's a
protest to vote you know can we tell
Dave Smith to change his name legally
right now Dave you're listening to me
right now please I get 10 on this idea
change your name legally right now to
ligma Johnson I love David I would vote
for him in a heartbeat but if we do
ligma Johnson that man is going to be
president if he legally changes his name
to ligma Johnson and the American people
see it on The Ballot Box in 2024 from it
there's no doubt there's no doubt that
American people will go for it no no
I'll tell you this with mail-in voting I
guarantee you if you go like so look
what is it you know 40 or 50 people
don't vote Yes you go to the door and
you'd be like hey did you vote the other
but I don't care about that yeah but you
can vote for ligma Johnson they're gonna
be like for real and be like yeah dude
Logan says lick my job they're gonna be
like done that's the independent vote
that's
that's the vote of the Stoners that's
the vote of the Ian's that's the vote
of the people that's the populist
working class right there that's going
to be like absolutely we need this
change dramatically I'm sick of the
two-party duopoly I'm sick of the bidens
the trumps I'm sick of all that ligma
Johnson 2024 I actually have a shirt
that says liquid Johnson 2024. but
that's a separate issue I I think it's
something that we could read and Dave
Smith
seriously just go to a football tailgate
to get those votes if any any yes so
many college you could go you're just
gonna have banners blips everywhere
ligma Johnson everywhere I could see it
remember remember when Deez Nuts got all
those votes yeah see yes Trump would
have a meltdown too if ligma Johnson
actually that guy legma Johnson don't
know who he is the wife's taking not a
very nice name
not very nice at all
yeah but uh
does it kind of does it does it take
away from you know if you were to
actually just get people to vote for
Dave Smith I guess it's idiocracy we
might as well meet people where they're
at right we might as well just go there
why not thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time